all right
friends Harry and Meghan Markle attended
the 2022 Ripple of Hope Gala in NYC on
Tuesday and Meg she gave a sweet and
subtle nod to her late mother-in-law
Princess Diana
that's the Duchess of Sussex looking
Glam in a white off-the-shoulder dress
with a thigh-high slit a black clutch
and matching heels but it's that blue
bling on her finger that really stood
out it's the same gem Megan sported
during her wedding reception back in
2018
and at the time a Kensington Palace
official confirmed to E.T that the
aquamarine ring once belonged to Diana
that aquamarine Cartier ring from
Diana's collection which had been left
for Harry he knew that it was always
going to be Megan's he waited until
their wedding night to give it to her
that's Meg on her big day waving to the
crowd flashing her new emerald cut ring
as they departed for their private
second reception you could see as she
was waving off in That Jag that that
flush of aquamarine are really beautiful
and lovely tribute to Diana Diana was
photographed wearing the sparkler at a
fundraising event for Christie's just
weeks before her tragic death in 1997.
she was also snapped wearing it in
Australia in 1996.
she would have been so proud and that
piece of jewelry proved to be the
perfect accessory on Tuesday night where
Harry and Megan were honored with the
Robert F Kennedy Ripple of Hope Awards
which recognized their human rights work
in mental health racial Injustice and
their social impact through the archwell
foundation they have really taken the
lead on talking about racial Justice and
talking about
mental health issues and normalizing
mental health whatever you think of them
I think it's a tough tough position to
be in I know the scrutiny you get and I
can't imagine dealing with it on that
level and I actually think that they're
doing a good job with it of course the
couple's red carpet appearance comes
just days ahead of the release of their
six-part Netflix docu-series Harry and
Megan
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth the six-part
docu-series which drops on Thursday will
show Harry and Megan's side of their
high profile Love Story it'll also
explore the clandestine days of their
early courtship and the challenges that
led to them feeling forced to step back
from their full-time roles in the
institution
pain and suffering of women marrying
into this institution is Feeding Frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want the
history to repeat itself but the
docu-series isn't the only big project
the Royals have in the works Harry's
Memoir titled spare will be released on
January 10th and we're told the royal
family is worried about it and I think
the greatest threat and the greatest
concern serving for the Royals is the
force coming autobiography which is of
course caused a lot of consternation in
Royal circles a lot of concern among
senior Royal sources and Palisades
because quite simply they don't know
what to expect
[Music]
foreign